and like those are the type of things
that like really
bring me to absolute tears like to
i might it might come out right now
because i'm thinking about people that
actually care about me
and like truly love me and like you know
that that to me like this to me is
bravery
is being able to be like it's
fearlessness it's being like like
dude i love the fact
that i can be i can be saved
at any moment you know and there's so
many things
outside this world that are like you
know my life changes every single day
lately like i'm on this like serious inc
like my whole career has been like this
but now it's breaking it's bending like
this it's like
and going through the roof dude and like
you know i'm getting these things that
i've always dreamed about like
like in terms of success that you think
about i'm
so changed by a sentence and not at all
by those things
those things don't change me this
podcast
exists because i love talking to people
and i love going deep the purpose
is to plant seeds of inspiration we
enter a space of vulnerability and
relatability and what you realize is
that we
are so much more alike than we are
different to quote ramdas
we're all just walking each other home
and this show
is just one step i'm danica patrick and
i'm pretty intense
[Music]
today on the show is a very very cool
human being
his name is maud's son he's a
singer-songwriter and he's really i mean
i guess probably
maybe the real word that he might even
want to be described at
i would think i'm putting words into his
mouth but would be artist
like he may he paints um he makes movies
he directs he sings he writes songs
and he just puts heart into everything
that he does so
i hope that you have fun with this
interview we go there he has an
addiction background but
he has come through on the other side
and as he would say his life has come
super ramped up in the last couple of
years and he has an album
out called internet killed the rock star
he has a
new song out with avril lavigne called
flames and so you're also going to hear
about how he's going to redefine what
rockstar really is
how are you fellow midwesterner well
super good midwest is really taking over
the world
that's good people who sit at four-way
stop signs and go like this no you go
no you go no you go oh i don't do that
oh okay cool
i'm doing amazing today honestly like i
just got um
some news that i i had been like preying
on legit like preying on
so um i'm just like i'm feeling a little
extra special today
you should you should i i i heard about
that and
uh when we first got on that's amazing
congratulations
it's like it's like it's that magic
it's those magic moments when stuff
happens that you've been asking for that
are
undeniable that it you can't help but
believe
in manifestation you can't help believe
but believe in the power of intention
and
uh you know asking for what you want
so like i mean i feel like you've been
in this space for a while
and i just want to say first off hell
yeah congrats
and um what up like tell me about your
tell me about your manifest
manifestation skills yeah um okay so
like i
fully fully fully have like
believed in that since i found out about
the law of attraction and the secret
like as simple as that the secret like
when i found out about that
um it just changed everything for me it
made sense i feel like for everyone we
are always doing that
anyway um but it's just like a whole
different thing when you hear someone
tell you that it's true and that's all
it took and that's like why
i really do most of what i do is because
like i know that
on like a karmic belief we do believe
that like you do
good and good is gonna come back to you
but it all just hits different when
someone that you admire
says it out loud like it's real and i
mean
i'm i am the epitome what i think is
like an underdog i've been an underdog
this whole time
and like i speak for those people i
speak for the people who are like
yes exactly and it's like this whole
world
wants you to believe that
miracles don't exist honestly we're
forced we're force-fed that every day to
think that like
there there needs to be like a
mathematic problem
into everything that happens in this
world and it's like yo at the very end
of the day
like we are living in a place that
miracles exist when you accept it when
you honestly believe it
and um to show that you're worthy of it
is i think like the pinnacle of why you
wake up every day
it's like when you're not supposed to
when things aren't going right and you
can still believe in the magic
and that it is going that way for a
reason
and that there is actually chess you
know i like to say like god is playing
chess
you know i say that all the time and
like thinking about
we all know that like we go through
these moments where we think
everything goes wrong and then we look
back on those moments five years later
we're like oh my god
like if that didn't happen i wouldn't be
here and this was all part of this
bigger picture and it's like if you can
just get
anyone that's in your life to watch you
and be like i will be the martyr for
this
i will totally forever be the martyr of
like
let me show you that miracles exist like
that is
all i care about and like yo talent and
skill oh my god i
hate those words perfection ill
i [ __ ] hate it i hate that [ __ ] like
i want to be the pinnacle of someone
that's like showing that
that you you are only in charge of so
much and that if you prove that you're
worthy for these things they're gonna
happen
they're going to happen you know and i
just want to be deserving of that now
also more than anything want to be
you know the person that stands on the
front line and fights for that
how do you prove you're worth it what do
you do discipline
oh my god discipline is so important to
me it has become
probably the most
important attribute that i have learned
because you can always add more
discipline to your life and like
it's so funny because discipline just in
general sounds like
such a boring word you're like
ew discipline what like i want to be
free it's like i have to
show that i'm worthy of getting what i'm
asking for
and like i do pray i've become very very
faithful in the last two years
specifically the last two years i've
become so
faithful and i pray every day and i ask
for things
like i'm being selfish i can't believe
how much
we have abused the word selfish
i i think that if you can't be at the
top of your list
and you can't help yourself first then
what is your help going to do for anyone
else
like you gotta help yourself first
you've got to
get your [ __ ] right and then your help
becomes meaningful
and you can go out and help people but
if you put everyone else to the top of
your list
it's like you're gonna die and you're
gonna watch someone else's life
you're gonna watch someone else's life
and like dude
you are here to make i say this thing i
say movie every day of my life i say
movie movie movie because i believe that
i
am making my own movie i want to watch
the greatest movie i've ever seen
when i die that's it i want to watch
this amazing movie of my life and see
all these
things that i created out of mid-air
and like if you don't if you don't just
add this discipline to your life
then you're kind of just unwillfully
asking for things
and like you know something so simple
like yo
i want to live i do want to live we're
just speaking to death i want to live i
want to live a long life i would love to
be
the oldest grandpa in the world and the
coolest grandpa still have green hair
all that
i would love to make it to being an old
wrinkly person
you know what i'm saying you can
redefine the 27 club by calling it the
127 club
thank you i have the 27 club all
tattooed on my arm
and like that that's the whole idea
right now new rock star vibe 120
reinventing
reinventing the rock star i say it every
day it's like reinvent the rock star
and um and you know just like discipline
is like the way that i show that i'm
worthy you know and it's so simple is
like
i run i run i run two miles
you know i run two miles a day and i and
i feel like if i do that
i'm showing that i'm worthy of getting
stuff i i feel like if i
am saying i'm going to you know we
all do we all slip up and we all enter
the ego
and all that it's like you can erase
all that negativity by positivity now
negativity is going to happen
acting out of ego is going to happen
losing your temper is going to happen
you can erase that
by doing the opposite acting out of
humbleness the next day
doing something for someone else instead
of yourself you can
totally erase that it's actually a
scientific fact that a positive thought
is more powerful than a negative one
sure absolutely well what i'm hearing
too is that
um you know i when you show up for
yourself it's it's basically like
when you don't put yourself first it's
basically self-abandonment
and so hit me in the heart yeah and i
doubt i've dealt with this too
like in my own way with my own things
where i
would do the same i would show up and
show up in other ways
other than for myself and that
self-abandonment ends up becoming
you know a real problem and then it
creates codependency issues and
so oh my god right am i saying all the
trigger words right so
yeah stuff that i still am working on
every day you know i
i'm with you and you know it manifests
in different ways but
when you know the selfish that we're
calling it that's uh
you know i had this conversation with my
mom actually because i had to do with my
mom the stuff the
the abandonment stuff and um and you
know mom kind of abandoned me on an
emotional level so then
in relationships i would abandon myself
in an emotional way
and and abandon myself completely and
serve other people and that just is
gonna lead to bad things and bad
partners
and um so uh she
said she was saying literally the word
selfish she's like
that sounds like if i do that it sounds
selfish and i'm like
no it's like when you learn how to show
up for yourself you say yes to yourself
which get
then allows other people you can show up
for other people the same way we can't
meet we can only meet someone at the
level that we're at
so if you abandon yourself that's the
kind of way you're going to show up for
people
so when you don't abandon yourself you
don't abandon your friends
and it's just it's very reciprocal it's
really the universe showing you you
and um so that's like badass that you
figured that out i think that
um i you know there was another thing
that i'd heard you
heard said it was um with your your best
friend machine gun kelly and it was
something he said i wrote it down he's
like
um taught you how to remain self-aware
but outside of yourself
and i was like that is such a deep
sentence can you explain what that means
to you
yeah i mean there is so much power in
zooming out
right um
standing in a room looking in the mirror
you see yourself you're looking
and you're staring directly into
what is presented in front of you there
is so much power in
zooming out like i want to be able to
understand
i want to see myself you know as as a
songwriter
just in general i have found out
that like the world sees you very
differently than you see yourself
and like you can learn so much
from zooming out and trying to see
yourself through someone else's lens
right it's it's like we are we are
obviously
individuals and we are seeing the world
through our lens
almost every second of the day to
actually
stop and be like you know that that's
why i bring up songwriting because like
i write songs for other people and i
like to have songs
of my own i like to write with other
people and it's such this crazy thing
that working with someone they could
write
the song that defines you better than
you can because they
see you how the world sees you and it's
like when you're force-feeding the world
i am this i am that i am this i am that
it's like the only true sentence is i am
so anything
that you put after i am this you're
lying you don't know you don't know all
you know is that you are
right and i am is the only true
statement you can say
everything that comes after that is
you kind of just talking about yourself
like a way that isn't actually always
digestible and like i've had such
a journey of trying to figure out how to
you know a lot of a lot of artists think
that the word like
relatable is like the devil right it's
like oh
then you're like losing your artistry or
you're you're dumbing down
it's like i want to be relatable
i want the world to be able to relate to
me and if i'm
acting out of this i'm one of one and no
one else is like me it's like you're
losing this
empatheticness and like i i was raised
by two women right
like i didn't have a father figure in my
life and like what these women did for
me
was allow me to say like i'll never
forget
my mom took me to my the first movie i
ever saw i went to a theater
we watched the movie stepmom right and
my mom
is relating to this movie on such a
hardcore level because it's about
dealing with like a single mom situation
and i'm sitting here and she's not
crying and i'm like this six-year-old
crying my eyes up
and had my father have been next to me
he might have gone hey
toughen up my mom's going
yes you know like i'm getting a vocal
talking about it
i was planted with this seed of being in
touch
with empathy and putting yourself into
someone else's position
i can almost see the world through
someone else's eyes better than i can
see it through my home
i can almost feel for other people more
than i can feel for myself
i would almost take i would almost take
that any day
being able to go you know what i i'm
confused as [ __ ] but i understand you
you know and and i think like that's one
of those things
it's like this this great duality you
know speaking of of
machine gun kelly like one thing that
that we go back and forth on like
the the simplest way to put it is like
we we do a lot of like
filming stuff directing stuff and stuff
like that together and like
let's say there's someone sitting on a
chair in the middle of the room
you know my mind is going everything
around that person is the art and his
mind is going
no the person is the art and i'm like
okay i get it i see what you're saying
but i also see what i'm saying and we're
gonna we're gonna meet in the middle and
create something that's
actually this duality of like coming
outside yourself so like
i love to be self-aware and understand
like my
brand i love to understand my brand
better than anyone
i love to to know myself better than
someone else i love that
but at the same time like i can jump
inside someone else's skin
so quickly and understand what people
are going through and i will be
the first to be open with the emotion of
like
feeling on a really really extra level
and and that's why i love like the idea
of being like
i had to understand that
i'm gonna put myself first i am
and while doing that you learn all these
other tools
about how to actually communicate with
people properly like communication has
always been like
this thing that's just like a constant
struggle for me
you know i
i i shoot myself in the foot a lot not
being able to communicate properly with
people
or expecting people to understand
right away where i'm coming from you
know and i've ruined so
many relationships by communicating
improperly
and figuring out how to walk that line
between
knowing and not knowing like i love the
sentence the only thing
that we really know is we know nothing
at all i love that sentence but i'm also
like [ __ ] you bro
i'm [ __ ] 34 years old and if i don't
know [ __ ] by now then what the [ __ ] am i
doing here
right so i'm gonna walk that line right
down the middle that's like
i know nothing and i know everything so
meet me in the middle
and we can have a conversation um
do you think that um first off i i feel
like you're just really an empathic
person
and um
do you find that sometimes it's hard to
articulate how you feel
clearly because it's confusing
great question let me like
let me like think about that so i don't
shoot myself in the foot again here so
like
say it again do i find it you find it
hard to articulate how you're feeling
because you're confused
you have to know because i don't have a
problem with being wrong
you know what i'm saying i would rather
try than be right
like i enjoy
i enjoy the moment so much like
i am the the definition of a person who
will actually
[ __ ] up if i prepare you feel me
like the more i think about who
i'm doing this great interview with
someone legendary like you if i'm
going to be sit and i and i mean that
thank you so much for having me on here
let me just get that out the way like
you're the best in the game we know that
like i love you for real
um if i'm going to sit all day and be
thinking about that and trying to
prepare
i'm going to get out here and be like
it's just it doesn't work for me
like i am a firm believer in letting the
moment dictate my seconds
you feel me so it's like everything that
that is happening in that moment like
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna lie to you
like
i do have this deep
burning desire in within me that i think
that i'm special
right i think that i'm important i think
that i'm special and i do believe i was
put here to be
i like to make art and i like to do
everything
as if i'm already dead truly i like to
think that i'm worth more
after i'm gone i like to think that all
the art that i make is
better after i'm gone and
while doing that like i kind of embrace
the confusion and i embrace the whole
like i would rather have someone seeing
me
figure it out than like acting as if a
teacher
you know i couldn't i couldn't in school
i could never vibe with the teacher
who's reading out of
an answer book you know and like that's
how i look at life i'm like you have an
answer book so like do you even know
what the [ __ ] you're teaching me
you know so i would rather be like the
teacher that's like
a martyr i love using that word it's
like i will go
down with the idea just to be the idea
if that makes sense you know and so like
yeah
there's times where it's like i wish i
could articulate myself
better and i could like take my time
more but i'm like
no i want people to see a human like
[ __ ] answer book
um well i think that you're a pisces
right
so um you live in the ethers
um it's a super dreamy state of being
and you're an artist which makes sense
and you're empathic and you can feel
other people
and so living in the moment is guided by
spirit which is always the best way
oh you're good you are good
now now you are very good at
articulating yourself
um you know i i i'm fascinated by the
human
condition i'm fascinated by reality
and human nature and um you know
everything down to like are we a
simulation are we zeros and ones
is this where do we go when we die and
what is consciousness
and you know what are dimensions and
like i mean i just
and and and how the human operates on
this
in this density level are you are you
getting closer to
those answers every day um
i mean i have my own conclusions right
now like right i think that's the the
the fun part about
learning is that um and experiences
is that uh as you collect them and as
being an open-minded person
i believe what i believe right now but
that might be different in uh
two months or two years and in fact i
hope it is because it means that i will
have
collected more information that helps me
make a better better judgment or
assessment of what's really going on um
so i'm fascinated with with with how
people operate and i think that we can
be kind of broken down into patterns
which is totally what makes me think we
might be zeros and ones like elon musk
says
um yeah i know i i i mean i like
bounce between it every day because like
i do
look like my favorite thing is like i
try to tell people like i'm always like
yo
yeah there is you have a witness at all
times
at all times this is why i say movie all
the time because i'm like
when you're by yourself like when i'm by
myself in my room and i wake up
i'll make it a point to be like yeah
love is good and i'm dancing
and i'm going like this because i'm like
i am doing that for myself but i'm also
doing that to show the witness that i'm
special i'm here i'm understanding that
like
i don't have to show up when people are
watching i need to show up always
you know and like i love to just to just
help people be aware that like everyone
deserves a witness
and like the things that you do
when you're alone are almost far more
important than the things you do for a
crowd
you know and so the idea of a simulation
is like it runs so deep with me
as far as like someone's watching
you know someone is watching me and i
want to be have you ever seen the movie
vanilla sky
oh yeah oh my god when they say the
quote mortality is home entertainment
like i dive so deep into that into being
like
i am literally you know the 27 club i'm
like when i make music i'm like yo
i was just talking to someone like i
picture my life
as a train on a track and i'm far away
from home
and i'm headed home okay and i want
all of my influences to jump aboard my
train at any point while i'm on that
track
and be able to ride with me and use me
as a vehicle and as
a vessel and like i so believe in that
and like the whole
idea is like life is entertainment is
just like
yes it's entertaining and it's also
entertainment for something else
you think so totally watching me like a
script yes
oh man that's a fun thing to think about
do you see all the alien stuff that
comes out these days and do you get all
jacked up and excited and going
they're here i'm ready take me i'm ready
beam me up scotty serious experience um
i would say like six months ago in
joshua tree with a guy named dr
steven greer have you heard of stephen
greer yes did you just
i know and i okay so i i went to joshua
tree with him like six months ago
okay tell me about it because i'm
tempted to do that sitting
in lawn chairs in the middle of joshua
tree in a circle with stephen greer and
doing a puja prayer
and all this stuff and um let's just say
like
yo i saw it yeah
i saw it and we had contact like no
confusing right no [ __ ]
no like no it's not no [ __ ] but you
literally saw it
no both orbs man orbs came what did you
see
um bursting orbs of light
uh you know a lot of this stuff he was
he was explaining to us
in in terms of like
we're [ __ ] down here that are like
don't enter our earth or we're gonna
shoot you down i mean are aliens real
yeah yeah they are like who
stop being stupid people like this this
is a big giant place we're not the only
game in town
come on and like how much fun are we
down here of course they want to join
the party bro
they're like duh so like you know i want
to hang out with mod
yeah so like we're sitting there and you
know i'll just say one experience that
like that like happened for sure is like
the temperature you know when you're
sitting out there asking
for these things to it was a really
beautiful thing because
it's going in my
in my i guess in my terms what i was
getting gathering from this experience
was that
alien life is is um
they're kind of scared of us they think
that we're we're
so uh frightened by them or
shocked or something so when you're
sitting there and you're saying
we come in peace just simple as that
we are not here to exploit
or shoot you down or hurt you like
you're accepting them into this world
and like definitely one thing that
happened was like we all
felt the temperature around us
raised by like 30 degrees literally when
you're in the desert at night it's cold
right
so like the temperature raised so high
that we all started sweating but it was
in the matter of like 10 seconds
and what we all saw was this giant ball
of light
completely encompass us and what he was
saying was we were taken aboard a ship
and like time exists in a completely
different way so what felt like to us
like the snappable fingers
yeah was like come on that that could
have been
so long and we are honestly like stellar
right
yeah and they have oh my mind [ __ ] and
like
he had a temperature gauge with him and
like it was
recorded that the temperature rose in
those matter of five seconds by like 35
degrees or something
um exponentially and like we all saw
this burst of light
around us and like um you know
i could go on and on about like just
seeing other little things but that was
like
the defining moment of being like oh wow
like this really happened and like i do
believe
that um i do believe that other life is
is down here walking amongst us you know
i believe in reverse
technology more than anything like the
story of valiant thor that goes back
into what like the 50s
like about you know how look at how our
technology has just
vastly gone through the roof and it's
like i believe in reverse technology of
of
another light source being like here's a
computer
take it apart and you will know how it
works i don't know what i'm doing
yeah that's what i asked steven too
is that some of the stuff that we see
like i live in arizona so it's like
hotbed i keep hoping i look up and see
something cool um because they happen it
happens here all the time
but i asked them i was like do you think
that it's actually our own technology
um reverse engineering what we've found
crafts and
and and seeing how it works and and yeah
that's the answer
um i like i get this like so you know
looping sort of old life new life in
there's
uh you know i i i think it's a really
brave and um uh confident thing
to talk about how you used to you know
look and idolize certain people that you
know
came and went too quickly and you know
the things
the things that we fixate on and put our
perception on become our reality
and so i keep hearing cool stories
about things that you're manifesting and
experiences you're having
and how some of these things probably
wouldn't have been possible without
a new sort of point of perception and so
um what kind of things have come into
your life over the last couple of years
that
uh you're so grateful for that are
totally different like weren't part of
your old life
yeah and for people listening that don't
know it's you know
having addiction and going into recovery
and
you know spending a lot of a lot of time
sort of spiraling to different levels of
addiction
and then to come out of that and be in
the place that you are now with such
perception of reality and yourself
uh and and all these new experiences and
being able to be present for them
that that like boom boom you just nailed
it
it's like it took me
so long to become present you know
i was so fixated on the future you know
there's this great quote that says
um depression comes from the thoughts of
past
anxiety comes from thoughts of the
future and like
if you can live in the present you can
somehow avoid those things
and um so my my story
is the person who was a hundred percent
like i was addicted to drugs i was
a extreme cocaine user like
through the room um all day every day
for a massive like eight years
um to the point that it almost took my
life and i and and what what it really
did to me
um because i do love like
i think you can gather that just by
talking to me for the last 20 minutes i
love life i love experience i
love this place i love people and i love
myself
and like every time that i would do
like that i was like this is gonna kill
me
and i was carrying around this suitcase
filled with shame
every day just walking around with this
suitcase of shame
and like is cocaine bad to do
yeah yeah it is it's a drug it's bad to
do
um you know what's worse than that shame
self shame it will hold you back
from all these beautiful things that
life wants to give you when you
feel undeserving of something
you are putting a red light on your
entire life
and i would get so close to the finish
line and then i'd say
yo i don't deserve this [ __ ] because i'm
i feel bad
like am i saying anyone out there who
does cocaine am i saying you're a piece
of [ __ ] you're a bad person
[ __ ] no not at all if you feel bad
someone was asking me the other night
bro did your life change because you
quit that [ __ ]
and i'm like i'm pretty sure just quit
beca
my life changed because i'm not carrying
around this self-shame
right if you feel like you're not doing
anything wrong when you're doing drugs
you're probably going to keep existing
and things are going to go great if you
think that you're doing something wrong
you are carrying around self-shame
that is going to stop you from all of
these amazing things that can happen
so for me i knew i was doing something
that was going to kill me
you know and and it and it damn near
almost did
and that was my like big wake-up call
was like
i need to stop doing this and i stopped
i put it down that day you know
i put it down i stopped drinking so i'm
almost
may 11th so i'm like what eight days
away from two years
of not having a sip of alcohol or
putting cocaine up my nose
and um my whole life has changed like
do i look more healthy do i look better
do i feel better
of course but guess what i'm not
carrying around this shame
i felt this is a shame i mean they're
like i get that they're shame oriented
with
something that you know you shouldn't be
doing doing something you know you
shouldn't be doing like you're like i'm
doing drugs
you don't walk around thinking good for
me you know yeah there's shame in that
but what's like the layer deeper like
why did you do it in the first place
you know um it's really that's a that's
a great question
um besides like the quick
fix and like the quick
heightened senses and and all that that
like something like cocaine will give
you
um
it was a pretty lonely world for me at
times
and to have something you can rely on
that's always there for you
was probably the most attractive thing
to me was like
i am the i am the person who's like
all i need in this world is myself you
know and
i don't need any of these people i just
need something i can rely on
and that happened to turn into like the
idea of a drug
that i could always count on and um
it didn't fuel my creativity and i
actually i don't think i ever looked at
it but now
looking back i can i can assure everyone
out there
that like you're not creative because of
what you're putting in your body
it is not fueling your vision
it is not doing that and i think that
you know when you do
actually quit something that is like a
road that i really really love to tell
people about to like
not be worried is like i've become so
much better at my craft and my
vision and my art and my statements
without it and with it maybe it was
actually slowing me down but like just
the idea that i had something i could
rely on that was
always there for me was probably what
it was and like honestly you know
when you enter like an aaa thing one of
the things that like
you get punched in the face with is god
i mean they're gonna talk about god to
you they're going to say
yo big macho man with your hell's angels
jacket on you think you're big and tough
like
god god god god like that's what they
talk about
and this faith and like do we know what
god looks like do we
do we know that god is even anything
more
than faith right no we don't but this
[ __ ] idea
of faith and that the one thing you can
rely on
is that is me going like this every day
like i
you know i look up and i say um dear god
i'm so grateful
thank you for giving me a body full of
determination drive desire
and a head full of dreams thank you i am
here to make the world a better place
please let me be a servant to you
all of god's children you know like i
say that
every single day and now i can rely on
that
i can rely on the fact that like i do
believe
that someone's looking out for me and
like before it was like a very lonely me
against the world type of thing
and now i really feel like it's like
it's like i'm part of a a team now you
know and like i always loved
you know i [ __ ] hated sports because
i wanted to be the absolute best like i
always want to be the best right so i
couldn't do like
i was a great hockey player but then at
a certain point i realized like my team
is my competition even because i just
want to be the best
on the team and like all this and so
like the sports that really got me going
were the ones that were like
i win on my own or i lose on my own i
don't want to lose because my teammates
over there [ __ ] it up
like give me a tennis racket give me a
golf club give me a skateboard
you know i want to take the win or the
loss and i don't want to blame anyone
else
and like i'm a part of that team now
more than anything which is like the
team of like faith which is like there
is something
bigger looking out for me that i can
rely on now
and like i can ask
i can fully ask for these miracles to
happen without feeling like an [ __ ]
you know you started
showing up for yourself and trusting
yourself
the inner child and you was going you
[ __ ] see me
i'm so happy you see me and then
of course you learned since that
relationship with the self
began to get better and better and
better your relationship with other
people did so now you can join the team
because you trust them because you trust
yourself
totally that's that's amazing and it's
like
that's a big shift so something has
happened to me so much like
something really big has awakened in me
where it's like
i love the idea that like like i said at
the beginning like i'm [ __ ] special
y'all
everyone better notice how special i i
love
feeling like that i can feel that by the
way and i think that's also
why you get to that near end point and
you're like no
no this isn't me this isn't where it's
going you have an energy
about you that i 100 you do you do
have that thank you very much for saying
that and
and like i have someone in my life like
my girlfriend that i'm with right now is
like
she is like such someone that i respect
and admire
because she like accepts me for who i am
but she's also very quick to point out
my fault
you know what i'm saying like my father
he passed away last year
on april 20th um from alcoholism
you know from being an alcoholic his
whole life and like
i have so many of his traits within me
which is like i'm gonna burn this [ __ ]
down right that's what my dad was like
he was like
[ __ ] life is here to be lived and if
you ain't [ __ ] living you're dying
like get busy living or get busy dying
you know
and do a lot with that energy yes and
and like
at the same time like i'm able to see
my faults and i love that we
all yo as special as i say i am i have
some [ __ ] demons in me
well that's to me you were talking about
relatability earlier and
you know i i mean and how like oh
stay away from relatability and get you
know stay on the pedestal
kind of a thing you're yeah yz up here
um and then i also and hearing you talk
about
making music and like also hating the
word perfection and i
don't think there is such thing it's
like when you become relatable
it's because you're showing your flaws
which
it literally is ever like think about
our inner monologue right
like we think about bad stuff all the
time we judge all the time
you should be this you should be that do
that do this we say nice things too but
we tend to have
so that's like where you connect with
people on that relatable level they're
like oh my god you screwed up i screwed
up
oh you look you know you sometimes look
in the mirror and go uh i look in the
mirror and go uh
and so it's the relatability that gets
you into the heart
through the feeling and so like i loved
hearing you talk about how you make
music and how
you know it's not about it being perfect
i did an interview with
moby and he was talking about how he
would
like he was like god nobody's gonna work
with me after this he said but
i was asking about having a song that's
or having a
you know recording a segment of the song
or recording part of the song and
and trying to execute it perfectly and
versus like the one where it's like a
little bit of a
you know you know your voice cracks a
little bit there's a little bit of
you know something going on but there's
like grit to it you know and i'm like
one do you pick he's like actually he's
like when i record people
he said i re i push record before they
think i push record
and he goes one word he goes okay i'm
ready because they like do warm up
and he goes no we're done yes and he
goes nice
we're we're done and wins dude that's it
exactly that's it how do you like to me
that's to me the like relatability is
meeting people showing people who you
are which opens the heart
right like how did you even to me i
don't know
your spirit's been asking you to do this
like your whole life but it's hard and
so
you kind of had to go through the trials
to get to the point where you could go
okay i can just like here i
am i don't know do you can you track
back where how it when it was hard and
when it became easier
yeah man like god you're really good
you're really good
like you're really good at this i know
for a fact removing the
i say this all the time removing the
bone of embarrassment from your body
i [ __ ] got so much out of that i got
so much
out of being like holy [ __ ] i'm gonna
start by trying to embarrass myself i'm
gonna start my freaking people out when
i walk in the studio
right i'll be around legitimately
professional singers classically trained
all this [ __ ]
i am the furthest from that okay i was
actually told my whole life
don't be a singer like my family
everyone around me were like
you don't got it kid play drums that's
it you can belt it
thank you thank you check this what i
really do
is i'll be working with these singers i
walk into the studio and i'll go get
beyond the mic and i'll go
just like that and i start from the
level of
like did that weird you out did that
make you uncomfortable
we we good now can now let's work from
there
let's start by trying to completely
make a fool of myself oh man
let's remove that whole air of like
i need to impress these people i need to
impress them because i know i impress
people
when i close my eyes and i just go
and whatever happens i say this all the
time in the studio oh
my the guy that i work with named john
feldman amazing producer
he will get like a track one he'll go
all right what are we gonna do and i go
i have no idea i'm gonna let god speak
and i walk in there
and i have no [ __ ] clue what i'm
gonna do and
all these songs just keep coming they
keep coming because i truly believe that
like
i don't need to be in control of
anything anything
when it comes to art like my art is
solely based on the fact that i
want to hear that inflection what you
said the growl the little crack in the
voice like
yo if you don't have that i honestly
think that i could put
a thousand different people in your
position it's the same [ __ ] thing
it's all good
i want to hear a one of one and that one
of one comes from
cutting across the dotted line i hate
that dotted line i'm never cutting on
that dotted line okay i'm always going
you see that you jack it up right there
you see that little jagged
lines color outside the lines yes [ __ ]
that dot
i want i want you to see every little
jagged edge every little
piece that is me that's me that's
my jagged edge okay anyone can cut on
that dotted line and do this little
pattern it's like
you gotta have this imperfection you
gotta have that there
to actually hit someone right in the
[ __ ] soul
you know and like i just i i know that
i i absolutely know that i help artists
out
and people in general by being like yo
you gotta figure out how to not be
embarrassed you gotta figure it out you
gotta understand that like the test
is to get up in front of people
if you can get up in front of people
and let this
soul shine it's so like i love
the corny quotes by the way i love like
details stars if you miss
i love them i see them all the time i
live by them
give me more of them i love them please
and anyone who thinks that [ __ ] is corny
like
really you're corny for thinking that
shit's corny because that should work
and like i get so much out of like
being a fool in front of people and
allowing them to open up
you know like and i know that's why
artists like to work with me is because
they're like
jesus this dude just literally is like
he's art he's [ __ ] art
he doesn't want to be this like paint by
numbers
you know he wants to throw the [ __ ] at
it you know the best thing about a
canvas is like
yo some of the greatest paintings of all
time
have been painted over by the artist
because the artist didn't think it was
done you know some of the greatest
paintings that could have ever
been seen have been painted over by the
artist because they're like it's my
canvas
it's my canvas and like yo i want my
canvas to have like this
[ __ ] just layers and layers and
layers and layers
i just want to keep building on it and
like that that's just
a way to live life is just take that
bone
of embarrassment out of your body throw
that [ __ ] in the trash
and like understand if you can work
backwards reverse engineer that [ __ ]
work backwards from being like
here's me being a total [ __ ] fool in
front of you
and and having no gauge of like caring
what you think about me
and then whoa you're gonna go whoa whoa
i'm impressed now still don't start with
impressing them
start with unimpressing well you don't
no one gets comfortable when they have
to be perfect
and that's kind of what happens a lot of
times and whether it's work or personal
is that when you know everybody's
putting on the front that everything's
got to be perfect you know like
tie and get them unprofessional and not
like looking perfect and acting perfect
and cooking perfect and doing perfect
you don't give anyone else permission to
be imperfect and so there's a discomfort
because that's nobody is
i love this i love this right here no
edit right like
what you me and you were sitting here
talking we're sitting here talking and
like
i look at these people doing these
youtube videos and all that [ __ ]
and i love it i [ __ ] love everything
that this this digital age has to offer
i love it at the same time i'm like yo
all these little edits where you're
trying to make yourself perfect is
what's ruining your whole [ __ ]
like give me an hour of you just looking
at the camera and talking
and i will take all the [ __ ] empty
space that you think is like bad
that's probably the best [ __ ] you know
and all these all these hyper cuts that
everyone's doing
is creating this whole ideology that
like the best [ __ ] comes from when
you're thinking and it's like
don't think at all actually and create
don't think create you know it's as
simple as that they
i recently went to egypt um in february
and uh well towards the end of the trip
we ended up at the great pyramid in the
sphinx and
um some of the girls were doing some
intuitive sort of channeling
and one of them is an akashic reader
have you ever had an akashic reading
yes yeah yeah oh you're so cool
you are so cool
so um she's doing an akashic reading and
i'm sitting next to her and i'm kind of
holding the energy for some for
for for some of the girls and because
that's what i'm good at
like you feel it all and i'm a f i'm a
[ __ ]
solid bubble like you can't get past me
like i'm
hard as a rock so i was there to hold
the energy
and i'm listening to her do the akashic
reading and
so she's recording it so i'm listening
and
she says that we get time all wrong like
we don't understand time again this is
coming from the akashic records her
speaking
and she said you know as as it's going
there's long pauses
and then she'd all of a sudden say you
know the records would say
look where your mind just went i stop
and i pause and look where your mind
goes
the cake is
the cake is the pause
and the frosting are the words and if
you think all you want is words eat a
plate of frosting
and i was like that is the coolest thing
i've ever heard i was like that's that's
she gets me so
i'm so turned on by that [ __ ] dude
you know what i'm saying yeah oh my god
i love that like that
that is enough what you just said is
enough fuel for me to get through the
next year you know what i'm saying it's
just little [ __ ] things like that
get to me oh man you know
just i love that you can feel so much
it's so cool like i
i mean this is like you you've had a
brave existence
if i can say like you've to show up in
the world to sign up for the job i mean
i tru i believe like we've gone there in
this conversation so
i believe you signed up for this mission
i believe you signed up for
the lessons and the people and the
experiences
and your soul is resilient and it went
oh you got this don't worry it's going
to be tough but
you got this and i know that you can
feel that you've already said that
what's what what what what do you what
is like lurking back
there that you're like nobody knows this
but i'm gonna do this
you know i wow
i do believe thoroughly
like i said earlier like i love doing
everything from the point of of being
dead you know
killing killing essentially the ego
or killing the present time
and like thinking about everything you
do
from a point of are you making the
future
are you impacting the future you know
and
i would so rather be understood after
i'm gone
than understood now in the present you
know i would rather be called a fraud
now
and a genius later and like i i so
vibe with the um the the
non-understanding of a human being you
know i
arm you have the 27 club the other arm
needs to people be like people like
nikola tesla oh yeah you know
oh yeah like edison or even some of
those sort of like
you know einstein people like that carl
sagan like
maybe one arm should be that the other
arm should be those people that people
thought were crazy
visionaries visionaries you know like
visionaries like
you know i'll never forget um i was
sitting with my mom
and i was sitting in our basement and
this was like i don't know probably 15
years ago
and um i looked over my mom
and we were watching tv and i turned off
the tv and it was completely silent
and i sat there for like a minute and
then i go what just happened
and she goes nothing it's completely
i was like what just happened to your
head in the silence she goes nothing
absolutely nothing and i was like
that's wild because i've never had a
moment of silence in my entire life
no i'm hearing you i get it i've never
had a moment of silence
in my entire existence because there's
always this voice that is in the back of
my head right
it is the lurking voice that's in the
back of my head
and it's always always there and this
voice is
so much more intelligent than me by the
time it reaches my teeth
it's vomit compared to what's going on
in here right like
it's just dribbling out it may be making
sense
back here this voice man i don't know
who it is
but it is so much greater than me
and like my whole ideology is to like
i love to think that like
maybe there is people out there that
don't have this like
voice always talking in their head maybe
there is
but maybe that voice is just asleep
and i want to wake that voice up i
really always
in entire need to wake that voice up
within myself and everyone around me
you know and let that voice out of its
cage like charles bukowski one of my
favorite writers of all time
he has this poem that he writes about
this bird that lives inside his chest
and he says all day i try to
drown it in liquor and i try to
suffocate it with smoke
but at the end of the day when i lay in
bed i can
still hear that bird trying to sing
and i'm like yeah that [ __ ] gives me
chills i just got
i got the chills too and i think we all
have that bird in us
that is trying to sing and we do all
these things all day to shut it up
and i want to get all these people in
this world
to let that [ __ ] bird sing and if i
can be again
a martyr for the person who maybe says
too much
just to get them to have that voice wake
up that is really my duty on this planet
you know
is to get that voice talking inside your
head
hmm i that was awesome
drop the mic drop the mic
no no come back more questions i always
have more questions
oh look what my shirt says dude listen
to the silence isn't that great
oh shoot well then i have too many
questions for you
i love this i can talk to you forever
honestly this is so great
um i i think that's so true i think that
the reason like i don't know if you've
done have you gotten to this point where
you
can feel body resonance with yeses and
no's especially guesses
like my body gets the chills like it's i
say oh i got goosebumps but then i look
and i'm like i don't actually have
goosebumps i think it's just electricity
i think it's just electricity i think
my chakras light up my body sends like
there's like a
it's like a resonant yes like frequency
wise
and it's a great really good indicator
has that have you figured has that come
to you
yeah like words touch me more than
more than a physical touch you see what
i say like like
i could be hugged by a million people
and feel
nothing but a sentence like let that
bird speak
is like the whole world
touching me you know that's when i truly
feel and like that's like
you know we have our our basic senses
and um
one of them is touch but like there's
also feel
and i think that once we once we evolve
a little more you get that extra sense
which is feel
and it's feel without touch and you know
that's that's really where i like to
reside in it's like
i know the power like like
it it seems it seems so undefinable but
like
really i know the power of like a
sentence man i know how much
something can change your life like the
course of your entire life can be
changed by
someone speaking to you and really
giving a [ __ ] about you
and like i think that's like what really
does it for me is like
i meet people in my life that i can tell
really give a [ __ ] about me
and like those are the type of things
that like really
bring me to absolute tears like to
because i'm thinking about people that
actually care about me and like
truly love me and like you know that
that to me like this to me is bravery
is being able to be like it's
fearlessness it's being like like
dude i love the fact that
i can be i can be saved at any moment
you know and there's so many things
outside this world that are like
[ __ ] man you know my life changes every
single day lately like i'm on this like
serious inc like my whole career has
been like this but now it's it's
breaking it's bending like this it's
like
and going through the roof dude and like
you know
i'm getting these things that i've
always dreamed about like like in terms
of success that you think about
and it's like you think your life is
gonna change like drastically when you
get these like monetary value of things
and
and and success that you've since 16
been like dude all i want to do is like
become a millionaire or like [ __ ] be
able to take care of my family like all
that [ __ ]
and it's like you know what i'm so
changed by a sentence and not
at all by those things those things
don't change me
the things that change me are really
like these relationships that i've
created
this power that i hold within myself to
be able to like you know
try to be a leader if anything you know
try to be a leader and that that it's
just those are the things that like i
can hold close to me
and like what you were saying about like
just like the getting goosebumps it's
like once you like really get to that
place it's like
you're perpetually there you're
perpetually there and like
you're not only like waiting for them to
come you're looking at them dead in the
eyes you're looking at
everything like holy [ __ ] that
that's changing that's affecting you
all of this right here without just
waiting for it to come
you're accepting it and just looking at
it right in the eyes and like this
conversation that i've had with you over
the last hour is like
something that like i know is
restoring like even more faith like like
you are an incredible human being
you really are and like i can feel it
just looking at like we could stop
talking
and me and you just continued the
conversation you know i feel that with
you
and god damn it we're lucky that that
this type of [ __ ] exists
you live there you live and feel land
yeah
and in fact you know and maybe this is
something for people that
have addiction and have um
ways of trying to escape reality is that
is hearing this is that you know you
live in the land of feel
and until you really so so a lot of
times what happens is people numb it
not because they can't feel like some
like feel
no point or pointlessness or not it's
you feel too much
you actually feel too much and so you
have to shut it off because you don't
even know where to start
and like it's it's a it's an
overwhelming
thing and so you know for for for
you to finally be in that place where
you can really truly express
and is that where the music comes in you
know loving poetry loving words
is that why music became your thing
great god another great question um
when it hits just right
that's my ultimate drug the ultimate
drug is when that volume is going on
and these chords are happening and these
sounds you know we're only given
12 notes in a scale and we're reusing
these 12
[ __ ] notes that's funny over and over
i mean quincy
jones said it [ __ ] point blank was
like
we got 12 notes we keep using them over
and over and we're coming up with new
things
like how how
unexplainable and these notes
you know i've always been that person
that's like
the idea of a visionary to me is like if
you can put on
headphones with a song and close your
eyes
does the movie start playing you know
and and that's
that's a visionary to me he's like when
you close your eyes
is it another world like on the back of
my eyelids is that the world
like really is that my whole world you
know because
like the wallpaper on the inside of my
skull is continuously getting more and
more
vibrant and beautiful as life goes on
and
i i truly think that like why i go to
music
over and over and over again is like
the one thing that has saved me is like
this
mystic overtone that happens
when the music comes on and it's like
that is my true escape from the world
it's like this
mystical overtone happens and like if i
could explain it i would but it's within
these 12 notes lies heaven on earth
and i go there every time and like
i there are songs to me in this world
that i'm not even me anymore when i'm
listening to them
i'm gone i'm completely gone i've left
this [ __ ] earth for three and a half
minutes
and those people saved
my [ __ ] life they saved my life
bob dylan is my favorite artist of all
time
okay and like when i would ride around
in my car in high school listening to
the times they are changing or something
like that
like that made me want to be
alive plain and simple and like my duty
is to reciprocate that in any possible
way
if i can do anything that music has done
for me
i need that then i'm i'm successfully
myself i just need to do for others
what it did for me and that all goes
down to the reason i write books the
reason i paint pictures the reason i
make
music it's all the same language to me
you know it's the the why why
can a song in
english translate to someone over in
tokyo japan who doesn't even understand
what i'm saying why are they crying
when they listen to it because it is a
mystical
overtone that exceeds language
and i don't know why it does but it
saves the human
it saves the psyche it saves the soul
and it opens up the door to your heart
like
you know i i did this this this uh
like breath meditation where you do this
thing where you're
and you do you know what i'm talking
about uh i don't know what it's called
but it probably
got you high yeah okay exactly you get
high off oxygen you do it for 15 minutes
and then you go into this heart prayer
where where it says open up the door to
your heart right now i want you to think
of one time where you truly felt love
one time where you truly felt
laughter one time where you truly felt
faith you thought everything was going
wrong and it worked out better i want
you to take those moments
place them in your heart close that door
guess what no one in the world has those
same things inside their heart and
that's what makes you
special and like i walk around with this
door open my heart as much as possible
to try to like continue to fill it with
my unique experiences and a lot of those
unique experiences come from the time
where i leave this earth for three and a
half minutes in a song
um god you got a lot inside of you don't
you
i can feel it you're like do i have
enough time to get it all out
for real i know i mean that's that's
like the the beauty of the
that's the beauty of the never ending
with art you know art never has a period
i think it's a constant comma
i think it's a constant yes but comma
here we go and like you know if there's
ever a period on
on something i do i try to open it up
with a comma you know
wow wow i feel like we've had such a
deep conversation i'm like
how do i go so internet killed the
rockstars your new album
i'm like this conversation's like so
much deeper than so you have an album
you know
you're so cool dud
i like to well here's the thing
when i talk to people and when this is
then you know
given to the given to the public to
listen to
it's the story it's like it's the story
that gets you pulled into
certain people or like i mean i make
wine so it's like the story of the wine
is why you drink the wine
partly if it sucks it sucks right if
somebody
you know if i made music i might not
listen to it but um you know you're
gonna come in for the story and so
when people hear you and they they're
going to feel something now when they
listen to the music they can
they can feel you and they know where
it's coming from and so we can talk all
day about the nuts and bolts of your
album
and whatever it's you that people are
really
buying into it like on the on when
they're gonna become a really
like dedicated fan and when they really
get it is they know you and then they're
gonna listen to the music
there's so much crap that gets promoted
day in and day out all the time
and it's the person i want people to
figure out not necessarily the thing
that they do
it's the person and so i don't even know
what there is to say about it other than
you have them album go listen check it
out if it resonates
great but people know you now and that's
it that's honestly it you know my
album's name internet killed the
rockstar because like how we opened it
up it's about reinventing the rockstar
you know what i'm saying
that like with every death there's a
rebirth and like that's where
um my career is taking me to is like i'm
trying to
uh put it all on table for everyone to
watch
i'm trying to be as honest as i can i'm
trying to make mistakes in front of
people
and i'm trying to you know spread a
message that like
yo it's first off it's never it's never
too late you know it's absolutely never
too late like
if if you're 60 years old and you listen
to this and you got something from it
and you are like damn maybe i should
make music then go [ __ ] make music
you know it is never ever too late and
like
i love that sentiment more than anything
and like you're absolutely right with
like
i'll tell you what i don't think i'd
have a
support group at all of people that
listen to my music if i didn't have this
story
because i don't make music that's that's
more special than
other people like i said we have 12
[ __ ] notes you know what i'm saying
and yeah i absolutely hope that people
can feel that like
i give my all for this [ __ ] i put
everything i have
into my lyrics i've mentioned charles
bukowski i mean
he's a poet like i study the great you
know what i'm saying i've
i've learned from them and i'm
regurgitating everything in my own
through my own brand new eyes but i've
i've learned everything from these
conversations
you know from studying like i really
don't
give a [ __ ] about the art if it doesn't
go back to the artist
it's all about the artist for me which
makes me interested in the art i'm not
looking at a painting going
well that's the greatest [ __ ] thing
i've ever seen i want to know why this
person painted it why they used that
color
and what period of their life they were
in and you know like with me i've been
lucky enough i've studied
art so much that like my favorite
artists of all time have famously said
every 10 years you recreate yourself
and your art and like i'm so grateful
for things like that because like if you
look
at my journey it's like every 10 years
i've entered this new era and like the
era i'm in right now
is what everything that we just spoke
about
and like you know i truly believe that
this conversation
will outlive potentially the music
anyway
you know it's all about what we can do
for the human condition that we're all
[ __ ]
suffering with a smile you know we're
suffering with a smile and that's
i love that like extraterrestrial sort
of like joker or like
you as a human come down and it's like a
thought bubble and it goes man i thought
coming to earth was going to be a lot
easier than this like why did i sign up
for this you know
like shoot i thought being a human would
be a lot easier than this
exactly this whole like this whole
existence
of um forgetting and not remembering
where we came from and
our potentiality and our
you know how great we really are the
fact that we can
think and create things i mean literally
like down to even the song right the
song that you write you literally just
bought it
[Music]
and then it becomes a thing and you
cannot play like a concept for a movie
and then all of a sudden it's like
something where people watch it you know
and you're like wow now it's on film and
there's all this stuff
and it's like my wine i like had an idea
or like my career
i had an idea to race and then all of a
sudden it becomes a thing and you're
like
wow it's a magical world and magic
and we're not surprised we're not
well i think that i think that
everything around us like all that we
don't see
dark matter dark energy whatever any
void
it's all just completely
filled with have you ever seen like the
way that a brain
is like neurological sort of networks
firing it looks like a web kind of
that's how i picture everything like the
reason why
time and space doesn't matter when you
get out of your body and into the
quantum
is because it's connected everything's
connected
and so i actually think that like
everything is connected and that's why i
can
we can feel at this distance right like
we can both get emotional we both can
get goose bumps we can tear up like
we can feel each other's energy is
because like we're connecting in the
quantum
on a level that we don't understand and
so magic is real
it's just that the reason why it's not
sort of believed in or it's not
it's not uh it's just called magic and
it seems mysterious and we don't
understand
it's just because there's no science we
shouldn't figure it out look when i went
to egypt
when you looked at the walls in egypt
you look at the temples and you look at
the pyramids and you look at everything
the one thing that you come away with
because like people were like how did it
go and i'm like
it wasn't like i had some magical
experience at some point in time
but what i totally realized was that
we're playing small
as humans and that we don't get it and
we're not
asking the right questions because
they're talking about the stories on the
wall when we don't even know how the
wall was made
god i know ah let the magic go
because the magic will become the stuff
that's called magic now will be just
things later
oh my god that's so cool you're so right
i mean that's that's like
that's that's the beauty of the human
condition you know
it's like is there like this like
magical evolution that's gonna happen
one day that's gonna click and
everyone's gonna like understand stuff
on a spiritual level
i i don't i i really don't know but i
know that
there are people out here that do exist
that way
and like you know magic is just
literally the accepting of it
it's like understanding that like yo
that's not a miracle
everything's a miracle once you like
open that door
and you say everything's a [ __ ]
miracle you're good to go
you're gonna you're literally going to
be pushed down
a path of beauty you know and like
whether or not you look left and right
and you take it in is up to you but if
you accept that everything's a miracle
like dude come on man like we're not
hippies for saying like
dude what the [ __ ] that is a plant
outside growing like
what how the the fact that everything
that we ever need is like coming out of
the ground is like
what the [ __ ] man you know but like
the fact is that there are people here
like that and
the more that these kind of
conversations happen is like
i think we're doing the right thing you
know i really do
you're away shower man show on the way
keep it up i love it this is amazing
yeah thank you so much this is really
fun
you're right i really i really hope that
like we're friends for life now because
like this was
this was really incredible this this
talk was great i needed it
i uh i listened to a few hours of you
and um i was getting ready and i was
telling my boyfriend this morning i'm
like
i didn't i don't i'm not as familiar
with your music and as i've consumed
more of
you i'm like i want to listen to your
music now and
i i mean i know of you but i don't know
like i don't like have an album
but i but i probably will now and anyway
the point is is like
i said like this guy's deep like i'm
like he's i think it's gonna be really
interesting
like you have a light to you that is um
uh yeah it's why you feel the way you
feel as i'm gonna mirror back to you
so again because existence is just
showing us ourselves
and so uh just like you said how look at
how people talk about you to know
who you are right so i'm saying the
reason why you can feel
that sort of drive that burning fire
that like
um determination that belief that you're
here for something great it's because
you are like i can tell that i can feel
that in the energy and so
um yeah thank you it's cool i really
appreciate this
yeah and and we'll we'll have to do it
again sometime this this conversation
seriously was like you're so great at
what you do so
so real quick i just have to say thank
you for having me you are like amazing
at what you do
and with your platform is amazing but
like this conversation was definitely
like the best i've had in so long so
thank you very much thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more please click on the subscribe
button